[Music]
we have an amazing demonstration away
safety glasses are important in the lab
it's a very simple demonstration sealed
tube of water heated up in front of some
Tomatoes two of the tomatoes are wearing
safety glasses two of them we used
Tomatoes because tomatoes are a bit like
eyeballs and we thought it would be much
too gruesome to get real eyeballs from
the butcher when we heat one of these
sealed tubes they called Krakatoa tubes
after the volcano that exploded
catastrophically in the late 19th
century as you heat it the water begins
to boil water turns into steam the
volume of steam is much bigger than the
volume of water so the pressure goes up
and up and up and can reach several
hundred atmospheres if the glass is
really strong then suddenly and pieces
of glass fly everywhere
and if you look at the poor tomatoes you
can see that the tomatoes without the
safety glasses were pierced by pieces of
glass one of them was actually peeled
gives a new meaning to having your eyes
peeled you could see where the glass had
gone through the eyeball but like all
demonstrations that we do we thought we
would do it several times in the second
run the glass tube wasn't strong enough
and it went off with a really quite
small bang in fact in high speed you can
see the tube flying away like a rocket
the third tube was an enormous explosion
really even neil our gallant technician
with a bit safer
[Music]
in this case the eyeballs with the
safety glasses were slightly damaged
because the explosion blew the glasses
up and of course in our simulation there
isn't a nose so some of the glass got
through the gap where you would normally
have your nose the protecting effect of
the glasses we call them glasses they're
actually made out of plastic
polycarbonate if you look close up you
can see where the plastic has been
pitted by the flying bits of glass the
safety glasses are probably not useable
again afterwards because of the
scratches but you can throw those away
you can't throw where your eyeballs more
than once
[Music]